welcome to waters world I'm Jesse waters
the lying rat falls flat that's the
subject of tonight's waters words
Trump's old lawyer Michael Cohen
convicted liar and tax cheat about to
head to prison for three years but
before leaving he became the Democrats
star witness and staged one of their
impeachment proceedings
here's Cohen in his own words I have
lied but I am NOT a liar and I have done
bad things but I am NOT a bad man sure
you're not now the media won't tell you
this but Cohen systematically destroyed
about a dozen left wing talking points
let's begin under oath
Cohen helped puncture the Russian
collusion and obstruction narratives
questions have been raised about whether
I know of direct evidence that mr. Trump
or his campaign colluded with Russia I
do not and I want to be clear mr. Trump
did not directly tell me to lie to
Congress the way if Cohen did have the
goods on the president Muller would have
cut a deal with him and he wouldn't be
facing any prison time at all
he obviously has nothing next he drove a
stake through the heart of the Clinton
finance dossier the centerpiece of the
dossier was at Trump sent Cohen to
Prague to hatch the collusion caper with
the Russians now that's a lie
have you ever been to Prague I've never
been to Prague never I have I've never
been to the Czech Republic
in addition Cohen said he had no
evidence that Trump directed Roger stone
to make contacts with WikiLeaks do you
have reason to believe that the
president explicitly or implicitly
authorized mr. stone to make contact
with WikiLeaks and to indicate the
campaign's interest in the strategic
release of these illegally hacked
materials I'm not aware of that
so Cohen also said that stone told Trump
in July 2016 that WikiLeaks was about to
drop all this dirt on the Democrats now
Cohen claims stone had advanced
knowledge but in fact stone knew just
about the same time as everybody else
knew because Julian Assange posted on
Twitter that he was about to drop
something so there's nothing there
speaking of nothing there Cowan
destroyed the campaign finance violation
a legate against Donald Trump
remember stormy Daniels was paid for her
so-called story in the fall of 2016
now these things happen when you're as
rich and famous as Donald Trump is he
paid for negative allegations to go away
to protect your personal and family
reputation Trump would have you know
have the National Enquirer President
David pecker buy the rights to the other
party stories catching them and killing
them I was involved in several of these
catching kill episodes but these
catching kill scenarios existed between
David pecker and mr. Trump long before I
started working for him in 2007 now this
is critical Trump had been doing this
for over a decade
therefore the stormy payment was not a
campaign expenditure it was a personal
expenditure not a crime because Trump
had been doing this for years and would
have done it regardless of the campaign
I should be a lawyer shouldn't I Cohen
also says he has no evidence of Trump
ever using the n-word I've talked to the
president over 300 times I've not heard
one time a racist comment out of out of
his mouth in private so how do you
reconcile it do you have proof of those
conversations I would ask you to use
tape recordings of those conversations
no sir and Cohen continue to knock down
a left-wing antitrump conspiracy
theories do you have any knowledge of
President Trump arranging any healthcare
procedures for any women not in his
family I'm not aware of that no is there
a love child there is not tonight to the
best of my knowledge in addition to
convicted russian mobster seder do you
know of any other ties to convicted or
alleged mobsters president Trump may
have I am not aware so Trump has never
paid for an abortion never had a love
child and never had any mob ties got it
thanks Michael it's pretty clear this is
a revenge plot by the Clintons
it's a bloody up Trump for 2020 now see
the guy behind Cohen right there
lanny davis the clinton fixer is now
representing trump's old fixer the fix
is in Landy's probably still getting
paid by the Clintons or some fat-cat
Democrat donor Cohen and Landy colluded
with Adam Schiff before the hearing and
have been leaking to the media like
crazy now remember the Democrats started
this hit job with the dossier then the
wiretaps and then the witch hunt Cohen
is being used and the millions of people
who voted for Donald Trump are being
abused